marked eyes rolled into the back of the
track he searched spit out Mountain Dew
and Cheetos out he looks like a dragon
and he starts swinging the joystick in
front of his body like a martial arts
weapons and for the first time I tell
fear my big brother died
[Music]
[Applause]
these guys are Pakistan good times and
sees the mode that's amazing please give
it up
oh yeah I have a story about my family I
think family is a pretty incredible
thing because it teaches you
unconditional love like seriously if you
think back to your childhood and if you
treated a stranger now as poorly as you
treated your brothers sisters and
cousins you'd be in jail right now
that's the truth
in my house a felony was committed every
day every day a felony was committed
blackmail extortion assault larceny arts
and more than once attempted murder it
happened all the time
because my big brother was the worst
offender he was a dick ok and ever this
one year for Christmas we all got
excited because we had to come together
in ask Santa for a family gift like a
big gift and I was like all what are we
going to get can we get a monkey right
like I didn't know it and my big brother
was like we're going to get an Atari I'm
like I don't even know what that is it's
like we're going to ask for an Atari so
we got invitar e that year for Christmas
and if you're not old enough to remember
what in the Tauri is it was the first
video game system for the house dude
right I do so many kids they're like
what do you mean you couldn't plan on
your phone no dude back in the day you
needed a quarter to play video games and
you'd run out so you'd have to go
through your house like the goddamn
Goonies looking for pirate treasure to
find another quarter I'm going like
where did that get check the couch there
we're going through my mom's old jackets
poker go we got quarters so you'd ride
your bike to a video game thing or maybe
get a ride to the mall and then you
could be at the arcade but then you
could be in the middle of the game and
three teenagers show up in Black Sabbath
t-shirts and you're like forget it I'm
not getting stabbed over cubers two
games yours
so so this Atari was supposed to bring
joy into our house but it didn't says my
big brother ruined it and it wasn't the
fact that he would just beat us in the
video games he would sing songs to us as
he was beating us in a game like he'd be
like you did your best
but I guess your best wasn't good enough
on my shut off through which I can't
relax it's just a game
still playing and then he kept quiet and
then right before the game was don't we
go to hear that and I go hear what he
goes to hear that I won because I think
it's Queen warming up in the background
now I'm shaking like McFly attend to the
back the teacher might be fat son of a
bitch it's on and I hit him but that's
what he wanted he wanted me to hit him
because he always me by a hundred pounds
and he start to choke slamming like
Andre the Giant a drop of a cold Kogan
legs and then pinned me for a five-count
like King Kong Bundy and then my dad
would be like son of a bitch ah once it
got bad game now my dad's running
downstairs he's breaking up the fight
it's like Chris go to your room and
Chris is like Steve started it he's like
well then you're going to your room too
hello out there
so my little brother knew he could never
beat out my big brother so he decided to
get a word counted video game
championship at a house yes my little
brother became like the lutea villain he
would wake up at 5 in the morning when
nobody was awake just to practice he
knew where my mom hid all the junk food
so he would steal like a 2-liter bottle
of Mountain Dew well before there was
red bull or 5-hour energy there was
mother at the Mountain Dew okay
twice the caffeine twice the sugar he
could get a warm straight out of the
2-liter he look like a rapper drinking a
40th day nights back in the 90s to be
like you know a little heart would start
getting Jack me to rip it open cheese
curls at 6:00 in the morning shoving
Cheetos in his mouth and that orange
cheese curled up and floated through the
living room like cocaine and the
departed
remember when Nicholson had he's like
then he would get excited and backwash
it into the mountain dude disgusting
because it looks like a bottle
Goldschlager with like just pieces of
stuff floating in there like one of them
snow globe so Markie got really good at
video games right but then some of the
kids didn't believe them that he got
that good at video games like why you
lying to make friends he's like I can't
thank you
so this is outsmart my little brother
one feels like I'm going to need
evidence so you bought a Polaroid camera
to take pictures of the TV set to prove
that he'd be gain some stuff and then I
remember this kid Jason was like we
don't believe you effect unreeling I had
something to show you
boom right I never resigned all that's
awesome
and then Jason was like yeah well how do
we know you did it in the next pictures
like my older brother hugging the TV
like I'm not my sister
so markup good at games
my big brother doesn't know this right
couple years had gone by I remember this
day vividly okay my Big Brother's on the
game console he's down there's warming
up he doesn't know Marx cotton is good
we are confident I mean we come down the
steps like Ric Flair and the four
horsemen Cochran I was like y'all might
not like it but one day you'll learn the
love at that boy let's rock mark
immediately starts lighting them up and
he's like it's awfully quiet over there
right it's like shut off and work like
okay relax it's just a game
hey Chris do you hear that and Chris
goes here what because I think it's
Queen warming up in the background take
a picture the stock banks when I win
so my dude where's your camera anything
I left it upstairs I'm like water could
connect in a dirty pebble so I'm running
up the steps and Mark not looking crisp
unplug his joystick oh oh my god I get
so much worse so much worse so I'm
coming down the steps and I just seem
are : I can't move my man I can't move
I'm going what I can't hear you
Queens playing too loud he's like Chris
wins the game immediately mark starts to
cry I hate you and when Mark pushes
Chris away he sees that that cord was
unplugged oh my effing goodness I didn't
think this could happen in real life
marked eyes rolled into the back of the
pack we first stood out Mountain Dew and
Cheetos out he looks like a dragon and
he starts swinging the joystick in front
of his body like a martial arts weapons
and for the first time I talked serie my
big brother died he was like hey dude
take it easy now it's over his head like
Indiana Jones it sounds like a
Blackhawks landing on our family room
Lisa so bad time and he starts to smash
my big brother in the face I'm like what
should I do a marquee like pac-man so we
double teamed on top of those mother up
and B's on them we're giving them a
ghetto for his feet down I don't know if
it's doing any damage but it feels great
on my takeoff please take that Marky
starts to take the cord and he's
wrapping it around Christmas broke he's
making noises like Luca Brasi in The
Godfather I'm like you're gonna kill him
so it's Bart's leaning on the choke I
kickers his legs start to shake and the
chubby fingers going back and forth like
that's a cool
like whole Cogan in the sleeper and he
just throws more more climb and he gets
up anything yeah kind of my hey man I'm
glad you won and he goes oh yeah
I'm glad I did this anyone boom right in
my face
no look there's a code to brother worse
passed down from generation to
generation will punch me to the face
everything else is on the books you can
throw a ninja star at your brother
launch a bottle rocket ever put his dick
in his bike and watch him flip over all
that's cool but no kickin to the balls
no punching to the face so he drops me
and I'm pissed I can help and I'm like
oh ha ha ha and this I'm dead mom and I
take off my hat now Creek is real calm
and he's like where you going I'm like
bitch and it just amigas you mean uh my
mom right my one get and get mom's the
woman you live with that's my mom
nobody ever told you that you were
adopted
marquis goes that's not true is it not
true that I punch you in the face no
because you're my real brother I punch
Steve in the face because he's a
stranger I was like um I'm still going
to tell go ahead tell my mom that her
real son had to punch her in the face
see what happens she'll make you pack up
your stuff and leave I don't have
anywhere else to go there is like well I
guess I won't tell so if you don't tell
you can just come down here and pretend
this didn't happen I was like thanks
he's an evil genius he punches me in the
face and I'm thanking up for it
so I didn't I don't have an ending to
that story so that happens you know to
me like it just I was really doing my
big brother was a jerk and had me
convinced for a couple years I was about
I get happened all the time we had
always fight we'd always say the meanest
stuff possible so then I was like yeah
if I talk about this on stage people can
relate to it you know okay only big
brother brothers can be mean and you
love each other through it and that's it
no you're awesome friends so one night
after a show this guy came up to me and
he was like you know what dude my big
brother same thing he used to tell me I
was adopted a long time
then I was like aunt her jerks right and
he was like what messed up thing is
years later I found that everybody was
and here's the thing though he wasn't
the only people started to come up to me
you know I could get like they have this
uneasiness about being adopted I'm like
oh my god this is not what I want to do
I want to put more love into the world
and remind people that family's awesome
and it's a little things and pizza night
and stuff you know and then the other
thing is like so I always thought I
wanted to adopt kids at some point maybe
because the time thought my brother told
me I was adopted for you
but right like I think what a privilege
it would be because getting back to that
whole unconditional love thing like how
amazing that would be so like one day
here my kids getting into a fight
downstairs and one kids like you know
you're adopted because like yeah that's
right bitch because mom and dad wanted
me they walked into a room and picked me
out
you're an accident you just showed up in
there like how are we going to feed this
one tonight and god bless you
[Applause]
[Music]